[Music]
well india is reporting its biggest
daily surge in coronavirus cases since
the pandemic began crossing the 100
000 mark for the first time the majority
emerge in the state of maharashtra
that's home to india's financial capital
mumbai
an evening curfew is being tightened
there and the lockdown will be enforced
over the weekends
seven other states are also reporting a
steep rise
hundreds of infections with virus
variants from the uk south africa and
brazil are being reported
well the rise in infections has not
stopped politicians however from
gathering large
mass crowds and election rallies like
those
the prime minister narendra modi has
held multiple rallies ahead of
upcoming regional elections health
experts are placing their hopes on the
vaccination drive
but the rollout has been slow only 76
million
indians have received at least one shot
in a population of 1.4 billion
elizabeth piranha has more from new
delhi
a day on day for the past two months
they've gone from an average of around
10
000 cases in early february to more than
100 000 cases on sunday for the first
time
in the past year again maharashtra
recorded its highest number of 57
000 cases on sunday and maharashtra
along with a handful of state
states account for most of the cases in
the country the other states are punjab
chatham madhya pradesh and
karnataka now here in delhi the cases
were 4 000 on sunday that's the highest
since
last year so prime minister narendra
modi held a meeting on sunday to review
the situation and he said that the rise
was due to what he called
the sharp decline in covert appropriate
behavior like wearing masks and social
distancing due to pandemic fatigue
and also what he called the lack of
effective implementation
of containment measures he is sending
medical teams to maharashtra to
assess why the situation has remained
the worst in the country there over the
past year he's also sending teams to the
states of punjab and chathaskar
to see why the death rate is so
disproportionately high in those states
now punjab has recorded has seen the
highest number of cases of the uk
variant of the coronavirus
but health officials in india maintain
that the variants whether they are from
the uk brazil south africa
even the double mutant variant that's
been found in india
that those variants aren't responsible
for the rising cases they say it is
because of people letting their guard
down after the numbers
fell as much as they did earlier this
year
let's speak to dr ishwar gilada who's an
infectious diseases expert and secretary
general of organized medicine
academic guilt he's joining us from
mumbai thank you so much for speaking to
us
and you are saying that this second wave
is stronger
than the first why do you say that and
what are you basing that on
see i'm based in mumbai and is a capital
of
maharashtra and financial capital of
india and currently we are in the second
phase of the pandemic where it is
surging every day and
yesterday we have notified almost
54 of the country's cases from the state
of maharashtra
uh and this has been a train for last
almost one and a half month
uh going on like that so what we see
today is
not just a days or two days work
working it is a couple of weeks of
cooking happening
uh behind the door or the virus has been
multiplying in last
three four weeks many fold and that's
what we see the result today
why do you think that there's been such
a dramatic surge in infections
considering that
india did go into months of lockdown
you see lockdown is not a solution to
prevent the surge basically
uh preventing service is a by-product
why we do lockdown is to
ramp up the services medical caregivers
the training
arrangement of beds oxygen ventilators
so basically
lockdown is for preparedness and now
what is being used
is for psychosocial impact on people
because people don't listen
otherwise so they either listen to law
or they listen to some punishment
currently punishment is not much so it's
only some
few dollars of fine but lockdown
helps people understand that there is
very serious situation
so if you say lockdown has been done
longest and strictest in the world and
that would have helped yes that may that
may have helped
uh for a gap between first search and
second search now we is
the longest gap we have seen anywhere in
the world okay so what needs to be done
then
next the the government in maharashtra
is announcing an evening curfew
and a lockdown yet another lockdown will
be enforced over the weekends
from what i understand you saying that's
not enough so what would you like to see
happen so basically what we are looking
at is
a combination of three things mtv
and mdb is not m television it is m
means
masking and that is most important so
for prevention
you have to look to the east look at
thailand cambodia
vietnam singapore hong kong japan they
have been masking
almost nearly hundred percent where in
india is masking is only 40 percent
and half of them do not use the mass
properly they do not cover
nose properly so masking is most
important and that will remain at the
main state
the second is t is the test
track and treat and that is also very
important when you diagnose cases you
have to treat them
and v is vaccination a lot of people
think that once vaccine is available
then we can prevent the second search
the vaccine is now currently which is
available
it is going to prevent the third surge
if at all it is not going to prevent the
current surge which is happening
and only if we uh use this combo of mtv
then we can contain kobe in a bigger way
otherwise we are going to have a major
problem
okay thank you so much for speaking to
us from mumbai
thank you